buenos dias santiago bien lo primero que
hay que entender que siria no es un solo
país sino que es un país que está
dividido en tres sirias la siria de
bachar el asad el norte del país que
está bajo control de los kurdos y es
donde se concentran los campos de
petróleo y una franja al este del país
que todavía sigue en manos de los
rebeldes sirios es en las zonas bajo
control del régimen de damasco donde hoy
se están celebrando estas elecciones y
que representan el 70 por ciento del
territorio nacional y es donde se
concentran la mayor parte de la
población porque ahí están las
principales capitales éstas son los
argumentos que dice el régimen para
hacer que estas elecciones sean
legítimas pero la verdad es que hay
muchos sirios que se han quedado fuera
un tercio de la población es soy
refugiada y vive en otros países como
aquí donde me encuentro en el líbano
donde hay más de un millón y medio de
refugiados sirios que pocos se han
atrevido a ir a votar por miedo a las
represalias o simplemente porque viven
en zonas alejadas y no tienen medio para
poder venir a la embajada
en el qué significado tiene para un país
como siria llevar a cabo este proceso
electoral qué significado también tiene
para bajar a los al asad que lo más
probable es que permanezca en el poder y
para la comunidad internacional que ha
tomado partido en este conflicto en
siria
bueno con estas elecciones bashar el
asad quiere afianzar su poder y de
alguna manera mostrar que siria es un
país estable pero la oposición ha
calificado estas elecciones como una
burla y la corona internacional también
ha criticado la falta de transparencia
en este proceso electoral ya que
prácticamente no hay un candidato
opositor que le pueda hacer fuerza a
bashar el asad y los que están hoy
compitiendo con el presidente son gente
que es cercana al régimen además como ya
hemos dicho antes hay una parte de la
población que no participa en estas
elecciones y esto hace que surjan dudas
sobre la legitimidad de los resultados
pero desde luego si podemos encontrar o
podemos dar una conclusión sobre estas
elecciones es que sin duda una solución
a la guerra desidia no está a la vuelta
de la esquina gracias a él por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de
beirut
dándonos detalles de las elecciones en
siria